fue interrogado durante tres horas en
una comisaria de Brasilia para declarar
sobre los regalos que él y su esposa
recibieron el rey de Arabia Saudita unas
joyas valoradas en más de tres millones
de dólares habían sido incautadas por la
aduana brasileña en la mochila de un
ayudante de gobierno cuando volvió de
Arabia Saudita y varios funcionarios
intentaron después recuperarlas sin
éxito otros dos paquetes de regalos han
sido devueltos al estado en los últimos
días por los abogados de revolucionaron
después de una decisión del tribunal
Federal de compras ella revolucionario
es sospechado de intentar apropiarse
regalos que pertenecen a la colección
presidencial y de intentar hacerlos
entrar de contrabando a Brasil este caso
afecta gravemente su imagen como líder
anticorrupción pero en total él tiene
que responder de 16 acciones en la
justicia
cualquiera de ellas podría impedirle
hacer elegido más que nunca Su futuro
político está en manos de la